vraiment surprenant ne diriez-vous pas que c'est un
faux bonjour qui parle
Clara a mordu pour être honnête je n'ai pas
encore décidé mais j'aimerais l'avoir
quel est le mot estimation
mesdames et messieurs cela me fait grand
plaisir de vous présenter le lot 231 et Miss
Claire  que pouvez-vous me dire d'autre sur
elle souffre d'une maladie très étrange
il lui parle mais à travers une
porte fermée porte fermée tu veux dire qu'il n'a jamais
vu son visage non seulement lui
personne n'a es-tu ici
tout peut être truqué Virgile pourquoi fais-
tu systématiquement  évite de me rencontrer je
souhaite te dire de cesser tout évoluer
dans mes affaires laisse moi avoir ta note
de frais bonne nuit hey Ann qu'est ce qui ne
va pas dis moi ce qui s'est passé comment c'est de
vivre avec une femme en train de
participer à une vente aux enchères dont on ne sait jamais
la vôtre sera la meilleure offre bien
quand vous pensez que vous avez réussi avec une
femme c'est quand vous perdez votre emprise sur la
stratégie j'ai besoin de vous voir
qui est-ce vraiment il y a toujours
quelque chose d'authentique caché dans chaque
forg  très